signs of What Lies Beneath steaming
cracks and crevices open up through the
Icelandic coastal town of grindvik
following weeks of incessant earthquakes
the town of less than 4,000 people was
evacuated quickly over the weekend there
are fears of volcanic eruption Could
Happen anywhere at any time the nearby
Blue Lagoon tourist hotspot has been
closed too authorities are now escorting
residents in one by one during a lull in
the Tremors we are waiting we are first
in line now to go into grind and you
only have a few minutes to grab things
activity from the nearby fogra dolls
fatle volcano has formed an underground
intrusion or stream of magma 15 kilm
long and right beside grindvik some of
the magma is now less than a kilometer
below the surface and the major worry
from a hazard and risk perspective is is
that the magma could come to the surface
and produce a Fisher eruption a Hawaiian
style lava producing volcanic eruption
that would happen if more magma feeds
the fissure fog doll's fatle volcano has
been more active in recent years locals
hope this underground buildup stops if
it does that it will slowly cool down
and effectively freeze solidify in place
it's also possible although less likely
that magma comes to the surface in or
near water creating an ash cloud similar
to the huge Icelandic eruption in 2010
that closed airspace on and off for a
month across Europe a temporary
inconvenience this event could destroy a
town we are in a in a big huge um
feeling of uh uncertainty and kind of
sadness and and and like despair there's
no planning anymore it's just really
just from one day to another ultimately
Mother Nature will decide Redmond
Channon Global News London